back to the big sunday show president
biden is isolating at the white house
this weekend while he recovers from
covid the latest written statement from
biden's doctor reads in part quote his
symptoms continue to improve
significantly his predominant symptom is
now sore throat and the white house is
doubling down on its defense of the
physician to the president who many want
to ask questions directly
the personal physician of the president
has uh has put out detailed reports of
how the president is doing every day
i speak to the personal
to his personal physician i speak to the
president every day
dr fauci does as well there's a whole
team of us in constant communication
and then you know we're getting that
information out to the american people
but a lot of people are questioning
whether we really are getting that
information in a timely fashion david i
want to start with you on this one
because they were telling us first that
he has omicron now we're hearing it's
ba-5 it's a sub-variant of omicron but
that tells you also a lot about his
potential condition maybe where he got
it we'll discuss that in a moment but
your thoughts on on what we're getting
how soon we're getting it
never let a crisis go to waste and to
borrow from tammy yesterday and keep it
going propaganda they used omicron as a
word to then spread more fear they
started certain states started reacting
this was almost a coordinated effort
then finally they announced that it's
the sub-variant ba-5 which by the way
according to some of my sources they
knew about yesterday and they were going
to come out with it on monday i'm
actually surprised they came out with it
today this is all about pushing their
agenda everything they do
look broader you know climb higher as
they say in the air force and take a
look at it you will see an agenda in
play and that's what biden has been
doing his entire political career this
is not new and biden's not that adult
that suddenly he doesn't know what he's
doing all the time fact is he knows how
to play to whatever audience and the
democrats the establishment kjp it's
funny we came in with tell me lies tell
me sweet little lies well i don't think
she even knows the difference because if
the binder doesn't have it she can't
answer a common sense question and she's
supposed to represent the president of
the united states i've known past press
secretaries from tony snow forward
secretaries on both sides of the aisle
who've done their job
she is incompetent this white house is
incompetent and that's a problem yeah
and now tammy the latest symptom
predominant symptom for him is the sore
throat that's not what they were saying
last week um but he's 79 years old he's
on blood thinners for example they're
giving him medications for this as well
and so you know the american public has
a right to get answers to some of these
questions to know how the president is
in fact doing uh indeed and also
i think when when they say it doesn't
matter where he got it that's what
kareena kept saying it doesn't matter
it's that he was prepared it does matter
we've been told for two years that it's
the science it's the data it's the it's
the tracing we've got to know where this
is going suddenly they just don't care
about that now
and that is is a worry if we really are
wondering about if this you know when it
comes to the variant
well it would matter about what was it
the in the planning what was it that he
did or did not do or if their planning
matters if it works that then should
inform everything else and and i think
that that's a worry we also one story
says in the washington post that he's
using an albuterol inhaler now i have
like situational asthma and i just i
just use the albuterol that inhaler if
there's a major issue and so that's a
steroid that has to go into your lungs
that is a major thing to know that the
president has to take on occasion in
order to breathe properly or to at least
contain some part of this omicron which
the difference is is that that lives in
the larynx that you lose your voice some
people do that there's a maybe that's
another reason why you're not hearing
from biden maybe the voice is affected
that wouldn't be unusual but every step
it's as though you can smell uh the the
observation of what it is they're
telling you the fear the lack of the
reality in every single thing including
when he says things like after a poll
that says democrats don't want him to
run he says oh they want you to run or
that the border is closed they keep
their statements have regularly if not
usually contradicted reality and i think
that's why we're concerned well you
bring up you both bring up kjp and so
let's listen to her response uh when she
was asked about this on friday
look i i don't think that that matters
right i think what matters is we
prepared for this moment
and then of course the doctor who comes
up to clean up on aisle seven
i think the question uh that the press
secretary was answering is can we look
back and figure out who infected the
president very difficult to do that it
happened several days before obviously
he developed uh he developed a positive
test uh and you know the president's
been out he's been meeting with people
he's been meeting with americans and so
it's gonna be very difficult to trace
back and figure out who gave it to him
so quick point on this by the way on
contract tracing and for everyone go to
the new york post and look up a story i
believe it's titled the five faults of
falci or something contract tracing is
one of the biggest or contact tracing is
one of the biggest frauds in covet
difference between tracking hiv or even
say a monkey pox versus contact tracing
on this it's proven wrong so they're
using shifts in narratives that don't
even follow scientific method now it
seems like they admit that because they
had all of us doing tracing back to find
out where we got it who had content oh
and an app on your phone was going to
follow you all right i did so i i had an
app from my hospital that i actually was
looking at going they're actually
tracking where i'm going
this white house for a year and a half
has been lying to us and if they're not
going to let us talk to the physician
hear directly from the physician my
antennas go up are they lying to us
about how sick he is and i hope he's i
hope he's going to do well i'm going to
recover quickly i disagree with his
politics but i want him to be healthy
but they're not being honest and
leveling with the american people which
is why you see them dancing all over the
place i think language actually matters
we're talking about a vaccine this is
not a vaccine everyone i know who's been
boosted and vaxxed they're all getting
coveted yeah the people who don't have
covet i i don't haven't been vaccined
aren't getting covered so why do you
have to call this a name no it's a
therapeutic but if they called it a
therapeutic everyone wouldn't have
gotten it and they were abs and they
knew it tammy you but if
they why did they need everyone to get
it if it was just a therapeutic but
tammy if if if it's a therapeutic what
studies have we done to show that it's a
therapeutic that works let's see i've
seen
it either
so we just go we're vaccinating
everybody
college
militaries are being forced to be
vaccinated and so i go why when there's
no data no science behind it it doesn't
make sense and what are the risks of
getting vexed we should have all that
information
next year they are all right we're gonna
have to leave it there hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not gonna miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now